happy tuesday reject nation
today is the day of the voting
day for the presidential election
best daily so with that in mind we're
going to watch from bad lip reading
debate night 20 20 bad lip reading of
the first
presidential debate i wanted to say
though before we go into this reaction
that you know today is a day where it's
very apparent
that the anxieties and tensions are very
high right now no matter what political
side you fall on
just keep in mind there's a difference
between you know
really even passionately expressing your
political opinions and and whatnot and
that's fine but there's also a
difference when it comes to
engaging with individuals who have
different political views than you
and then going about it in a hate-filled
way
so let's all we're all kind of stressed
it's been a tough year
let's just do our best today
to be a little bit more mindful and
respectful
yeah let's try if you voted you did your
part
and uh maybe take a breather for a
second or find a way you can
help someplace else for the time being
yeah yeah we need a little bit more love
in the world and
it might be a bit of a challenge for
some today
anywho let's watch this video where
they're making fun of both candidates
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah such fun now the first question is
where should i put it
in the chunk i stick it in the lasagna
what
okay
is there something that you have to do
right now right into yourself
hey look at me little jingles you need
to hold papa's hand
well someone answers the phone the phone
get the phone what there's no phone
that's ringing
no right there they're ringing i don't
hear anything
oh boy oh no are you embarrassed
i'm mortified yeah chris i would like to
use
the c word
butt chunks
i don't feel that's safe with a lot of
people i hope someone has an epic pen
because i'm frighteningly allergic to
corn
but chunks oh wait a minute then that
would buy the corn
[Music]
your favorite nickname for yourself
your favorite bill the gas spill i'd say
your favorite animals wow
ashtray
oh great vice president biden
your turn now this is more organized
than the actual debate
i kind of wish there was a component
like this
[Music]
your favorite body part nostrils
your favorite meat penguin and your
favorite
good job that wasn't bad you know in the
90s he called the pages
stupid pagers yeah
a grove of wheat that just depends on
whether his horns
are horns it's all about the horns now
some people have horns
for humans you see and they usually slip
on down into sinbad's hole
that toxic sewer and nobody should be in
there
you know except for the horrifying
bleach bird
you don't say but today we're gonna
make a pig roll in a pumpkin down in
brazil
you know what for most brazilians frogs
have to go in the breakfast series
[Laughter]
facts about what's happening in brazil
sorry to make it about me but my
youngest nephew kevin told me how you
found some really good frosting
it's icy no it's frosting if you cut
icing frosting you should beat yourself
trust me i am like your flesh everywhere
[Laughter]
yo i don't even know those people who
snowboard and go off and have a big day
okay man why are you so psycho
stop it so you agree that he should stop
then no both of you okay
yeah you cow uh some fat no
you're not fat you see i was only
described you bruised my big on by
[Music]
it's kind of hard to believe you're the
hopes of the
if you cooked i probably wouldn't chew
anything i would just spit it
hey pork chops what are you looking at
so i just remembered my dream from last
night there were these
little tiny meat people who were my
favorite friends though i admit they
were real oily
and they were like good job papa and
then what happened was
they brought home the little baby
me right now i am not super great at
pointing you're pointing at you
i'm not trying to point at me right now
what form is to wear a point
it's
[Music]
up in a sexier way you get it
i do i do get it it's time
to it's time for the most important part
of the night
yeah we'll give you various situations
and scenarios and then you
both act them out okay
going first we've got papa pizza johan
you questioned what your wife bought you
for your birthday i have to own a spider
tank
you're more upset than that
[Music]
i have to have to own a spider tank you
spot your neighbor a proctophlepticus
blubberman
oh hey a man who thinks his candy is
alive
hey i have these gummies and all these
gummies have
brain a romantic movie scene with harry
styles
wait harry your worst possession would
you have in your pockets in my heart and
sweetie
i would like you detective just learning
that all of the victim's stomachs
contain words that have been cut out of
magazines
that's weird i think these were people
that were on a paper tag
you send your baked potato back to the
kitchen needs more nutmeg
your favorite sesame street character is
going through a rough time during the
holidays
big bird cried in my stuffing saturn
my stomach nice
[Music]
you cut tiny strips of paper to accent
the miniatures in your dollhouse
yeah i have scraps that will fit in the
little typewriter
right after watching the movie babe your
girlfriend asked what you want for lunch
well not a hot dog
i'll never touch it again i'm done with
that
you're a cop who just caught his partner
trying to steal diamonds from the
evidence room
de santo the ice you've got to leave the
ice
tony that was our faith they're not even
acting oh wait no they're not
well now that i've had a cream soda oh
tony's upset
tony it's okay it's all right picks up a
crosstalk
don't do it put it away dear tony no and
scene vpb the emotion
was gripping are you running out of
vengeance
de santo
[Music]
a young man is having trouble making
friends and asks you for advice
oh well angelo
maybe it's your face it's already gotten
to me
you find a zit while you're taking a
shower uh-uh
there's a pimple upon my birthday you
let melania know you're
in the mood hey the peepee is tingling
what are you farmer people farmer people
look at your bigger mustache and you
must be on petunia
you can play into the flight attendant
there's no pizza in this plane
he offers you toast
[Music]
between a pharah and a frog i fear it
that frog hates to hear you sneeze by
the way
your hiking buddy suffers a terrible
injury and your miles from any help
best to glue on the pain you don't have
the glue put the peen in the purse i'll
offer you a chocolate milk hey you got a
parasite
you're a hairdresser touching the back
of a client's head while she stares in
the mirror
hey thank you she asked you to take off
her mask
let me ask you dude why
you describe the zoo to a young child
the zoo it's just a gross park
tower a homeless man asking for spare
changes
uh yes beverly could you give me a rice
cake
the powerful monarch tells you she's not
interested in dating you
oh wait empress i have a greek body
just let me be your emperor baby you
want that
too for them right oh
not too fast actually i know i brought
these types of coins they are supposed
to make new flowers
hooks
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know if these arms or wings that fly
away people on fire
need help and people not on fire can
lend to help
why do you and everyone else think with
their feelings man you're a
bronze goblin
you always smell like musty bean water
like bean cups or something vote for joe
biden
not a maggot oh you got dandruff you're
a dirty cow sack yeah
you'll flee for me you should buy the
sword
you know what guys i just sort of
imagined that i put my head inside of
the stall
[Music]
oh my goodness bravo
boy oh boy well done america just won
for that boy oh boy you know that the
second presidential debate
was uh a much better one
they really had to uh yeah you know
well your mics and stuff so that one
might not have been as like
crazily entertaining that's not we're
supposed to get from a debate is chaotic
entertainment
uh but you know like i think this first
presidential debate is
one for the history books just because
of how insane it was
yeah this was one of those examples of a
piece of comedy that starts to coalesce
with reality for me because watching
that first debate
was very kind of sensory overwhelming
because there were so many points being
made so much talking over
three people at a time often talking
over each other and throwing out remarks
and this video did the same thing to me
where it got
at times overwhelming and then i would
kind of come back in
and you know the thing is i can imagine
at a certain point both these guys
saying any number of these things
just because of how crazy all this has
gotten and how much you know for better
and for worse trump has shaken up the
method of discourse you know i mean i
think that the way that they handled
this video though was just
really fun like at the end of the day
all they wanted to do was make it really
funny we actually watched like the
uh epic rap battles version which is
very like politically heavy on both
sides yeah yeah and this
one bad lip reading just kind of
captured some of the personality traits
that we make fun of
exactly form them which i thought was
really great it's like character-based
comedy
yeah and in a way that somehow at least
to me kind of managed to be non-partisan
because it is
nonsense most of it and just playing off
the fact that they all hate being there
with each other
and so i can almost imagine that no
matter where you fall on the spectrum
this video would be entertaining yeah i
feel like there's something that's kind
of a cathartic release from it because
you got the moderator who just
progressively just wants to keep dying
jazz this keeps going more creative
trump with his like very aggressive
weird point of views and then you got
biden who kind of
trails off yeah a little bit sad
about something i thought that was a
great capture of the personalities
yeah and i love that they added a game
element to it and made it
because it felt like a weird game show
to behold the real thing and so
to watch this actually have game
segments and then for them to be able to
zero in and do kind of a medley of like
yeah okay here's prompts and now we can
use both their body language and the lip
reading like it was a pretty fun
application of just this brand of comedy
yeah
i thought it was great i personally
really enjoyed it and it was way more
organized than the actual debate i'm
eight percent less stressed in the polls
right now
i mean i'll end it with this on bad lip
readings video that i think no matter
what political side you fall on
i think you can enjoy this video you
know i endorse
this one in those videos like doesn't
really matter if a democrat or
republican on this one
this is just really funny or libertarian
or kanye guys
it's a weird day today it's gonna get
weirder
let's just do our best to
become and and engage with the process
because that's why the process is here
and if you're upset then stay informed
and take advantage of the next moment
all right guys well subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell
subscribe to bad lip reading if you
haven't done so already thank you so
much for being here
we'll catch you guys soon and patron of
the day shout out
adelia chamberlain adelia i know that
today especially can be one that might
stress you out
just a little bit so i wanted to step in
here today and tell you
how grateful i am to have you in our
lives
i was so happy to go on the let's get
ready to talk shmodown podcast we both
did it uh recently thank you everyone
who went and checked that out
it was adelia who actually coordinated
that whole thing which was
actually the only reason i said yes to
it so that's right
that's how much you're right that's how
much influence and power you have in our
lives adelia getting to actually talk to
you for a little bit
face-to-face at least yeah zoom was uh
great after all this time i got to see
your beautiful face hear your lovely
voice
you are a gem in my life and i hope that
you can
do whatever you can to just breathe
keep calm stand out talked a lot about
politics over the past couple years and
so i know how today must be for you but
i just wanted to say you have a great
heart
you have a lot of love you have a lot of
support and you have two individuals
here who really care a hell of a lot
about you as well
and thank you so much for everything
you're the best love you delia